[Music]
hi there i'm
wishing pasty a very happy birthday i
want to share some of my favorite
memories and videos
to celebrate pasty's fifth anniversary
i joined tasty 2016
april and it was exciting and
new i was hired as a tasty japan recipe
developer
i was always interested in shooting
videos
and i was always curious like how it's
made
so i was very excited for my new
journey so my first video is a little
bit embarrassing
but there is one video i'm still proud
of it went viral
that video is animal shaped eggs phobias
this is my first viral video i remember
when i was
little i enjoyed eating boiled eggs
shaped like rabbit
my mom prepared for me so it's basically
you
decorate boil the egg and just make it
look like rabbit
just one rabbit i felt like it was not
enough
so i decided to make different shape of
animals
so for this video i made rabbit hedgehog
owl and mouse for the rabbit
i used black sesame and cara
for nose for the hedgehog i used straw
and
used black sesame for the eyes and black
whole paper
for the nose for the outs i used green
olives for the eyes
for the mouth i used carrot for their
ears black sesames for their eyes
and pink peppercorn for their nose so
this video is very special to me because
my mother used to make this
rabbit-shaped egg for me
and maybe in the future i'm going to
make one for my son
it was so cool to see a lot of people
tagging their friends
and saying like let's make this together
i'm glad to see the video
inspired a lot of people and probably
that was
first time i realized how powerful food
video can be
2017 by 2017 i was comfortable
shooting food videos but it is my first
time
being in a video this video was fried
chicken cook-off
and i showed how to make japanese-style
chicken wings called tebasaki so when
you cook fried chicken
i think a lot of people is worried about
if it's completely
cooked so the method i showed in the
video it's a double fry
you fry lower temperature first
so you make sure chickens cook through
and you raise the temperature
so chicken is crispier so for tebasaki
fried chicken
we usually use potato starch to fry
we call karage for the sauce i use
soy sauce milling sake sugar
and garlic so soy sauce mini and sake
i feel like that is holy trinity of
japanese seasoning
so we use it for a lot of dishes
the sauce has a very intense flavor
so you don't need to season akchow
chicken wings
and i kind of tossed with sesame seeds
it's optional
but i think it kind of gives a nice
toasty kick to it
even though i was very nervous on camera
it was
very cool experience sharing my recipe i
always make a home 2018 was one of the
craziest
and busiest year at the tasting another
video i'm very proud of
was dampening around asia so i showed
this video for
asian pacific american heritage month i
wanted to showcase dumping recipes
from different cultures i asked my
co-workers
to share their own recipes the first one
is
korean mandu i thought it was
interesting because he used tofu for one
of his ingredients
and from there he adds pork beef
scallions
onions and kimchi i think mandu is
unique
because they put kimchi in it it has
very flavorful and spicy kick to it
it was so different how i make my
dumplings so it was very
fun to watch him to make mandu
so next dumpling is made by lisa and
she is chinese american i thought this
stampeding
is very close to how we make japanese
dumplings
she uses napa cabbage i think one cool
tip from this cooking
is sprinkle salt to napa cabbage so
you can extract moisture from napa
cabbage
if you don't do it it's gonna get very
soggy
dumpling while you're cooking so next
one is nepali momo
my co-worker sanjana showed us how to
make nepali momo
i've never had momo before the
interesting part for me was
eating with chutney i thought it was
very interesting
because she used turmeric garam masala
and ghee and she used chutney as a
dipping sauce
and it was so delicious the final
dumpling
recipe is my own and this is my mom's
recipe she used a lot of neera chives
the unique way of preparing is i think
when you fry
these dumplings because we make slurry
and pour over to make this crispy edge
we call hane it's crispy and it's
delicious i'm so glad
to make this video because my mom
doesn't use
recipe she just eyeball everything i had
to measure out
everything so i can make it same every
time and
end of 2018 we saw our very first
make it fancy i thought it was very
interesting challenge
because i have to think outside of the
box and i'm not used to
cooking with a lot of rolls so it was
very challenging to me the first episode
we made is ramen fancy and i used my
holy trinity
sake medium soy sauce and i fried
the ramen block also i use everything i
use like
seasoning came with that so i'm pretty
proud of what i made
if you are watching make it fancy
from the beginning you might remember my
hands were
shaking because i was very nervous so
the first episode
i created this snakey fuzzy dance
make it fancy make it fancy we didn't
plunge it or anything it just naturally
came to me
i feel like making fancy was very catchy
title so i was like oh it's like make it
fancy
at that time i didn't know it became
my signature move since then we made
more than
20 makey fancy episodes which is
crazy and because of make you fancy i
get to try
a bunch of ingredients i've never tasted
before i
never tried lunchable foods
you name it i never try it but i think
it's
also challenging because those
ingredients are new to me
i'm excited to make more new episodes
2019
i started making more youtube video
instead of recipe video and i started
making more documentary style video like
how it's made we visited mexicali
and chef estoras he showed us how to
make
alpa store i never knew how to make
the trombone like alpa store and it was
really cool to see
also i went to beekeeper's house and
i saw how honey is made i didn't know
how
honey was made and it was really fun to
learn new information so one of my
favorite
show on tasty is aijuri cook i've been
in a lot of episodes
and it's always fun to work with kids
and make their crazy amazing imagination
to real life dish one of my favorite
episode
is fairy episode linda was very
energetic and she was so much fun
she drew shooting stars and she wanted
something
powerful so i put pop rocks
in a dessert so i wasn't sure she had
pop rocks before
one of those noises in my head
stop it she had a quite cute reaction
one thing
really cool about this episode i get to
compete against
alex hashtag relics she's my bff
it's always fun to cook with her 2020
i started producing this video series
called
recipe exchange student where i teach
my recipe in japanese
all right you're gonna need to slow down
on that one also like my coworker
teach me their recipes in their language
perfect five i really like this series
especially the one
i shot with alex i tried to teach
alex how to make inarizushi which is
one of popular style sushi in japan
so recipe is a little bit complicated to
begin with
and on top of that you have to teach her
in japanese so it is very challenging
but she did a great job and we made
juicy
inaudible so it's a koi challenge but
cooking is its own language
so and also they do a lot of body
language
it's super fun to learn other cultures
cuisine
and the food is so good i think one of
the coolest thing about tasty
is we are showcasing a lot of different
culture
and cuisine and audience can learn
recipes from
all over the world i think that is
really cool again happy birthday tasty
it's been a great five years and i'm
excited to
many more happy yachts to come oh yes
[Music]
you